hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the finals of the 2021 tata still
chess tournament uh we are in the thai
breaks it's anish geary versus jordan
van forest and
this is the armageddon game the first
two games uh ended in a draw so first
they played
two five-minute blitz games uh and then
uh of course comes the armageddon before
we check it out i would just like to say
that this
has been uh such a such an intense round
uh
the round before the tie breaks and the
tiebreaks as well so full of drama that
is just
it's just hard to handle and i will
discuss more about this and what
happened in the alireza game as i know a
lot of you are interested in that
because i will show
alireza game also uh but for now let's
stick to this one so anish geary against
jordan van forest and this is it
uh so gary with the white piece it's
armageddon giri must win
if it's a draw or if geary loses then
jordan one forest
wins the tata still 2021 so without
further ado let's check out what happens
here
giri with the white pieces opens with d4
we have d5 and bishop to f4 geary goes
for the
london system or the immediate bishop
before also known the accelerated london
system we have knight f6
e3 and now c5 and they're going to play
a very very standard line that has a lot
of theory
uh regarding it we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and
knight b to d2 now uh we have e6
and now c3 so just the nicely developing
pieces
bishop to d6 and now bishop back to g3
asking whites to capture here so you can
get the nice semi-open h file for your
rook we have
h6 and now there are a couple of games
where bishop the d3 was played also nice
the e5 is a known move
but the move gear replaced bishop to b5
is a new move so already as of move
eight we have a completely new game
so here uh we have bishop back to e7
uh and now comes knight to e5 putting
pressure on that
knight on c6 so queen to b6 attacking
the bishop
and the gary defends it with a4 uh we
have castles by both players so castles
castles
uh and now a6 pushing the bishop back or
asking do you maybe want to capture on
c6 so gary captures
we have b captures on c6 and now d
captures in c5
bishop captures and now b4 further
expanding on the queen side
bishop back to e7 and now a5 chasing
away the queen we have queen to b7
and now knight to d3 ah the knights are
now coming to see
five this knight is coming to b3 and
then you're going to have nice control
of the c5 square
and white has a very firm grip on the
position with control of the
c5 and e5 square black will not have
all that many breakthrough possibilities
so here knights to d7
also adding some control to the d5 and
c5 squares and
knight to b3 now we have queen to b5
and here just knight to d4 first chasing
the queen away
queen to b7 and here rook to b1 you're
preparing some uh pawn pushes on the
queen side here we have knight to f6
and now knight the c5 so here
you either allow this knight to remain
here and it's such a such a powerful
knight but you can't really allow it to
remain there because the bishop controls
this entire diagonal the pawn covers
this
so the queen would have to go somewhere
like a7 and uh allow
knight captures on c6 so the knight has
to be captured
so bishop captures b captures queen to
d7 and now
rook to b6 and this can already be
considered uh
maybe even a winning position for white
especially with uh so
not a lot of time on the clock it's a
very very difficult for black to hold
this
so here uh knight the e4 going after the
c3 pawn
so gary grabs in c6 where rook captures
knight captures on c3 and
now queen to c2 pushing the knight back
knights to b5 and now
rook back to b6 and now uh giri has
excellent support of the square so he's
ready to push his pawn
but now knight to a3 going after gary's
queen
and here gary should just play queen to
c3 ask this knight what do you
what are you doing here and after the
knight moves then continue pushing his
pawn however
giri goes for the uh sorry not knight to
see
knight to c3 and now c6 so
uh this is what gary goes for he attacks
the queen and offers a queen trade but
that's not what you should do here queen
to c3 like we said
is the way to go and then c6 but giver
he decided to go for it right away
and uh decided to trade queen so here
knight captures on c2 was played c
captures on d7 and now knight captures
on d4
and here we have e captures on d4 you
don't have time to capture this and
bring a queen into the game
because knights the e to check saves the
knight and only then will the queen be
recaptured
and then black just has a better
position maybe it's
equalish but black has nothing to worry
about so after knight captures on d4 we
have e captures on d4 and now
bishop captures on d7 and now rook to c1
so from what was a really really uh you
know
overwhelming position for white now we
have a position where black is perfectly
fine
and white doesn't really have a clear
way of even even making problems for
black so here
bishop to b5 you are no longer you no
longer need to worry about that pawn
uh and especially it's uh an engine
where there are opposite colored bishops
so if the rooks come off the board it's
it's a dead draw
so bishop to d6 attacking the rook we
have rook f to c8
and black of course wants to trade all
of those rooks and now
bishop to c5 not allowing the trade
rook to c7 preparing to double up on the
c file
and rook to e1 now and here just rook
eight to c8 and here van forest says
uh okay uh whatever you do here uh i'm
perfectly fine the way everything is
so you know i'm just gonna wait and you
figure out how you want to continue here
and gary has no other option but to
start pushing those pawns so he goes for
it
f4 we have h5 by one forest and now
king to f2 uh we have king to h7 and h3
gearing needs to push pawns otherwise he
can just uh
accept that it's a draw uh we have king
to g6
and now g4 we have capture sanji for
captures and
now rook to c6 offering a trade of rooks
with rook to b7
now rook eight to c7 again offering a
trade rook b8
rook c8 again offering a trade rook b7
rogue b7
uh rook c7 and asking uh white are you
maybe interested in a draw but giri of
course cannot afford a draw
because in armageddon the draw means
that van forest wins the entire event so
giri has to trade
we have captures captures and the now
rook to e5 so gary waiting like
like a true predator uh we have bishop
to d7
uh and now rook to g5 with check trying
to create some
uh some chances here maybe but it's
going to be very difficult king h7
bishop to f8 but now just g6 and
everything is nicely defended
uh we rook back to e5 and now f6
pushing back the rook rook to e3 and now
king to g8 so chasing the bishop away
bishop the c5 and now rook to b7 and
there simply is no way for whites to
make progress here uh there's just
nothing to do
so here uh bishop to b6 not allowing the
rook to become
too active with bishop to b5 uh
black says okay you figure out what you
want to do and here even
giving up the e6 pawn which is which is
very interesting but if it works
why not real capture is now king f7
pushing the rook back
uh we have rook back to e1 and now rook
to e7
this is how uh van forest says okay we
either trade now and i know this is a
draw or you move the rook and then i
activate my rook
as the e2 square is nicely guarded by my
bishop
so here rook to c1 and we cannot afford
the rook trade because then it's just a
draw
we have rook to e4 now with an attack on
df4 pawn
so king of three gary defends it and
then now bishop to e2
with check king g3 now rook to e3 with
check we have king to f2
and rook back to e4 again attacking the
pawn here and gary cannot continue doing
this otherwise we're just going to have
a
draw by threefold repetition so rook to
c7 checked by geary we have king to e8
and
now g5 gear is pushing trying something
but
it doesn't appear like there's anything
to be done here
however here if i gave you like 10 tries
you would you will not guess what
van forest played next because there's
simply no explanation to this move
sorry what gary played next uh sorry
what van forest played next because
there's simply no explanation to this
move
um it's uh probably uh probably he
thought
okay i'm winning i won the tournament
everything is over there's nothing uh
else i can do here in any move i make
is just a draw and then he literally
just made any move and here
believe it or not when forest played
rook captures on f4
and that's just uh that's just insane
and here of course geary is now
completely winning
uh gary captured the free piece he said
thank you for the piece
the problem is after he captured the
piece
uh we have f captures and g5 by one
forest and
now gary played the rook to a7 but the
problem is
his time ran out before playing rook to
a7
uh which means that giri lost the game
on time
and also means that van forest won the
game and also
won the entire event and the thing is uh
this was move 58 so gary needed only two
more moves to reach time control
uh yes there is also time control in
armageddon
but uh he was unable to do so and
somehow uh he
he he you know lost on time which which
is just crazy and and also heartbreaking
uh he lost uh
last year to magnus in the tiebreaks now
losing to van forest in tiebreaks he was
supposed to be
the dutchman to to win it this year but
the other dutchman won
so a very tough tough break for geary
and especially
uh i don't know i don't know what to say
but it chess is
ruthless and you know someone has to be
on top but uh
you know i don't know congratulations to
one forest it was this is a huge victory
for him
he not only won the super tournament at
age 21 he also won some
30 something i think 30.2 rating points
and so now he's
i think he's over 2700 uh now in rating
which is just incredible and also i
would just like to point out that in the
first blitz game they played
uh this position occurred where geary
had a completely
winning move but it's an incr incredibly
difficult move to spot
but just for fun feel free to pause the
video and try to win this position for
geary in round one
of the of the playoffs while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
uh at least giving giri this consolation
prize and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's g3 and the g3 is such a crazy move
to play here you are giving up this pawn
but what you're doing uh other than that
is that after captures you have now
cleared the second rank completely
and now rook the d8 is crushing this is
what gary had in position but
it's a blizz game you can't see
everything problem is even if you try
blocking this rook just rookie 2.
now the rook is coming to e2 and if rook
for example g1 blocking this
rook to f2 you cannot stop rook rook
coming to e2
and let's say g4 rookie 2 and that's
game this is this will be checkmate and
if you try something like rook g3
uh you're just getting crushed rook f1
check you have to block with the rook
but now just bishop to g to check only
move king to h2 now bishop captures an
f3 a nice discovery
king g3 now you pick up the rook
captures here and now you just go back
and you have
of course a completely winning end game
so this was in the position in round one
i forgot to mention this but uh giri was
unable to find
this uh after this f3 gear he did not go
for g3 he played h5
and then one for us to just eliminate
gary just eliminated this and
uh one forest was white in this uh
position
uh so the photos don't
trick you gear is actually black here
but then one forest captured
captures captures uh and there was
nothing more uh to be done here
and then of course the game ended in a
draw uh so yeah just wanted to mention
that
uh and yeah really really heartbreaking
for gary but
uh you know what you're gonna do that's
that's how it works
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
enjoyed it we're gonna show one more
game at the alireza game that also had a
lot of controversy to it so
stay tuned for that as well i would like
to thank aditya suresh kumar
jake cotton kevin juan caitlin quinn and
robert clayton for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continue
not continuing but we are going to show
at least one more game from the tata
still
uh checking up on your one of the
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day